Mẹ mình sau thong tạm, ông Karon Noricky chính thức tuyên thẻ nhập trước tổng thống balan, trong bài phát biểu đầu tiên chú cô hội ông tiên đủ một môn thay đổi hình pháp để bảo vệ chục quyền của gia.
Phát ngôn này lập tức trong ngờ tăng thẳng với thủ tuyên đường nghiệp đồ năng tất, người đăng muốn được balan SICK Lại gần Lý Minh Châu Âu.
Tổng thống Noricky, sinh năm 2018, là người theo đuổi đường đổi dân sọc chuẩy á và được hậu thận bởi tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng trăm.
Ông phản đổi nhập tư trải phép và nói không, với đồng ero.
Dù không liều dọ chỉ tế xử hình pháp, ông kêu gọi giới hạn quyền cán thêm của liên mình cho ủ vào vấn đề nối bộ.
Huyến thống thống balan là người có quyền phủ quyết lật và đề sất giữ lật dân.
Dều cũng thể khiến hát đồng lạnh đạo chỉ đạo của chính phủ bị cản chờ.
Nếu thống thống và thủ tưởng không của tế ngoa chung, sau bài phát biểu của tổng thống Noricky,
phía chính phủ balan phản đổi mạnh mẽ phó thu tụng quyết stock của gọi cào sĩ đình đối sẻ không hật đa.
Căng nghỉ xíy lên mình tầm quyền thích tóc trong khi đảng bảo thu, về ý át ăn mừng tẩn lợi chính chi,
và tìvọc, tổng thêm quyền lực vào kỳ bầu cử hội, năm 2018.